[Music]
author and cbs news contributor ibram x
kendy is expanding on the lessons of his
best-selling book
how to be an anti-racist in a new
podcast
the weekly series be anti-racist with
ebromax candy premieres today he will
interview guests like former cabinet
secretary terry julian castro tv
personality don lemon
and author heather mcgee the
conversations will focus on how to build
a just
and equitable world in the first episode
candy and disability rights activist
rebecca coakley
explore how racism and prejudice against
disabled people
are intertwined take a listen just as
the notion of a colorblind society is
bullsh
so is the idea where people say see the
person not the disability no i need you
to see my disability and i need you to
see it as a fundamental part of who i am
and for able-bodied people to
no longer imagine themselves as normal
yeah
just as white folks should not imagine
themselves as
as normal and men should not imagine
themselves as
normal definitely hebrew mix candy joins
us now even good morning thanks for
being with us
oh good morning thank you for having me
at the beginning of that conversation
you have with rebecca coakley
you asked about the terminology
terminology we should use
uh when discussing disabilities and and
you say that
we should learn to humbly approach
conversations
explain what you mean
well i think what i've learned over the
years
talking to people from different
communities
i've learned that people in different
communities have their own languages
have their own terms have their own ways
of understanding and seeing the world
and identifying themselves
and in order for us to make bridges and
cross bridges to different
peoples we have to understand where
people are coming from
and we have to speak their language yeah
and part of the reason for launching
this podcast you say is
is that the topic of race and and racism
is much broader than than many people
think it is
it is and and i'm someone who is a
student and a scholar
of racism but i'm always learning
because there are so many different
forms of racism from racism in housing
to the environment
from racism affecting native people from
racism
affecting black women and so that's what
i wanted to really do is speak to
experts to really learn and and
and join with other people as they're
learning too i learned a lot listening
to your podcast ibrahim i have to say
i never thought about racism and ableism
you know you tell a very pointed story
about your brother who you said has some
mental health issues
that the police were called to your
house and how fraught you were with fear
about what could happen could you talk
about why you were
so concerned i think like
like many people all over the this
country who
who have a loved one uh who's a person
with a disability
when i got a call that my brother was in
a crisis
and he had called the police all i could
think of
was fear and all i could think of was
was try to get over to my parents houses
as fast as possible because i know
unfortunately
uh police officers are not trained uh to
to respond to a mental health crisis and
so i didn't want anything to happen to
my brother like has happened to so many
people with disabilities all over this
country
on the subject of learning there is a
push in schools across the country from
republicans in particular to emphasize
the more patriotic in their view
elements of our history
as opposed to some of the darker
chapters in particular
not teaching the idea of systemic racism
as a college professor yourself as
someone in the education business what's
your response to that
i think i i am sympathetic to teachers
and
educators everywhere who are committed
to doing our jobs
and our job is to tell the truth our job
is to tell the good and the bad
our job is to tell the light and the
darkness and i think that's what
students want and i know i've had so
many students who've come to my
classrooms in colleges
angry that they did not learn about
systemic racism and even about slavery
uh during their k-12 leaders you know
you said your podcast at one point
racism is harmful to white people i
think white people in some blacks are
going huh
what you're talking about willis so i
wonder if you could just briefly explain
what you mean by that because you said
when racism wins we all lose
well let's just take a current example
we of course have
talked about the the way in which voter
suppression policies are
disproportionately disenfranchising you
know black brown and indigenous people
but it's also disenfranchising and
making it harder for white people to
vote
it's making it harder for all of us to
vote you know in these states
well you give people a lot to think
about even kennedy so bravo to you thank
you so much for joining us this morning
ahead thank you for having me you're
welcome